- Okay, well, welcome everybody.
And thank you so much for coming
to today's event on
climate policy and politics
which is sponsored by the Policy Lab
and the Institution for
Social and Policy Studies.
I'm John Dearborn, and I'm
a postdoc in the Policy Lab
and the Center for the Study
of Representative Institutions.
And I'm going to help
moderate today's event.
Before I introduce our speaker today
I'd like to begin by thanking Limor Peer
And Pam Greene for all of their hard work
and helping to coordinate
and set up this virtual event
as well as all of our events this semester
and the ISPS policy-related
skills training series.
I'd also like to thank
ISPS director Alan Gerber
for his support of our
virtual programming.
And I'd like to encourage
all of our students
in the audience to check out our schedule
of ISPS policy-related
skills training events
over the next couple of weeks.
It's a pleasure today to
introduce our guest speaker
professor Leah Stokes,
a political scientist
who is leading the field
in studying energy climate
and environmental politics.
Leah is assistant professor
of political science
and an affiliate with the
Bren School of Environmental
Science & Management
and the Environmental Studies department
at the University of
California, Santa Barbara.
Within American politics.
Her work focuses on
representation and public opinion
voting behavior and public policy,
particularly at the state level
and within environmental politics.
Her research examines, climate change
renewable energy, water
and chemicals policy.
Leah's book "Short Circuiting
Policy", seen here,
published in 2020 by
Oxford University Press
examines the role that
utilities have played
in promoting climate denial
and rolling back clean energy laws.
It received the 2020
Best Energy Book Award
from the American Energy
Society and was listed
in the New York Times five
climate books from 2020.
I also have to point out
as a scholar of American
political development myself
that this phenomenal book
is part of Oxford studies
in post-war American
political development series.
And what an amazing work
of APD scholarship is this.
Leah has also contributed
to the anthology.
"All We Can Save", which is a
collection of essays written
by influential women in the climate space.
Her academic research has been published
in some of the top journals in our field
such as the American
Political Science Review
and the American Journal
of Political Science.
And she has also published articles
in such outlets as the New York Times
and the Washington Post.
To our audience as I
said, I will be moderating
the Q and A portion of today's talk.
I would invite you to submit
questions if they occur to you
during the talk itself
via the chat function.
And once we go to the formal Q and A
I will call on folks using
the raise hand function.
I would also that this event
is being recorded during the talk itself.
I ask that you please mute yourselves
and turn off your videos.
And Leah, thank you so
much for joining us today.
- Well, thanks so much for having me.
I've spent a little bit of time at Yale.
It's a great community, and I
know a little bit about ISPS
and it's really a wonderful
place to be studying policy.
So I'm thrilled to have the
chance to share with you today.
So I'm just gonna share my slides
full screen, okay, great.
So today I'm gonna talk about my book
which John did a very
generous job introducing
it's called "Short Circuiting Policy".
And I'm also going to talk
about some of the policy work
that I have been doing with
some of the recent reports
I have released on clean energy
which inform a lot, some
of the conversations
that we're having right now
about how to decarbonize
our electricity system.
So the challenge that
we face is very large.
We have to clean up our
electricity system quickly
in order to decarbonize our economy.
I often say that cleaning
up the electricity system
is the first linchpin in
economy-wide decarbonization.
Why is that?
Well, if we do clean up
our electricity system
it allows us to electrify
large parts of transportation
through things like
electric vehicles, buildings
through things like heat
pumps and induction stoves
and also parts of heavy industry.
And when we add up all these sectors
we could get two emissions
reductions of between 70 to 80%
through clean electricity
and electrification.
So before the last couple
of years, we were talking
about 2050 as the timeline
for clean electricity.
And that was because we were talking
about economy-wide decarbonization
on those timelines.
And you can see here that
if we set a benchmark
from the year 2000, and we
draw a straight line up to 2050
then essentially each year
clean power has to grow
by two percentage points annually.
And although this ends in 2018
the data from 2020 is actually 40%.
So we're directly on track now
but what you should notice is
that we've been really living
on borrowed time with our
nuclear and hydro power fleet
which have been largely flat.
And in the case of the nuclear fleet
have a large potential to be declining.
And so we actually need to renewables
to be growing much faster in order
to keep pace with this timeline.
Now, this isn't the timeline
we're talking about anymore.
We're talking about
decarbonizing the grid by 2035.
This is what president Biden
campaigned, and one on.
And it's very active area of
discussion in policy right now.
So under that scenario, we actually need
to be growing clean electricity
by about four percentage
points every year.
And that doesn't even take
into account the growing load
that will be necessary to
deal with electrification.
So that four percentage
points could be masking,
you know massive growth in the
overall electricity system,
meaning that it, we don't just
need really 100% clean power.
We need like 200% clean power.
And so that could be rather
than four percentage points
on a 100% basis.
It could be like eight percentage
points on a 200% basis.
So there's a lot to be doing very quickly
if you're interested in these arguments
and trying to kind of get a sense
of what I'm talking about here
actually made a video,
which summarizes this
argument from my book
it's called the Narwhal Curve,
and we released it with Grist.
And it's quite a nice
little three-minute video
which kind of gives you
the basics of these ideas
and can be used in classes
or shared with other people
who maybe don't know a lot
about the electricity system
Now my book looks at the state level.
And that is because the federal
government has really failed
in terms of amplifying clean electricity
throughout the 1990s advocates,
try to pass and fail to pass
renewable portfolio standards
which are the main policy
I'll be talking about today
sometimes called clean
electricity standards.
They're very similar.
What it is, is a policy
that says by a certain year,
like 2035 we have to
have a certain percentage
of our electricity
system from either clean
or renewable sources, like
100% clean electricity by 2035.
So these renewable portfolio
standards were developed
in the 1990s and advocates
were trying to get one passed
through Congress, but they failed.
And I tell the history of
those efforts in the book.
Now, the closest we have come
was just over a decade ago.
In the Waxman-Markey
Bill which you may know
is the very large climate
bill that passed the house,
but did not pass the Senate.
And that policy included
a federal renewable portfolio standard
for 20% renewable power by 2020.
And it actually had a provision
that allowed 8% of that
to be met with energy efficiency.
So that policy, when I
looked back on it for my book
it wasn't considered ambitious at the time
but what's so interesting is
that when we look back on it,
had we pass that policy
we actually would have been
further along than we are today.
No, of course if Biden Harris'
campaign was really focused
on 100% clean electricity by 2035.
And this is something
that the administration
has also signaled.
It is planning on working
towards this year.
So in the absence of federal
action on clean power
States have really been leading the way
and throughout the 90s
and early 2000s, a majority of States
passed renewable portfolio standards.
And then later on expanded
them to higher percentages
and expanded them to include clean power,
which usually includes nuclear
at the carbon free resource
potentially carbon
capture and sequestration
although that largely does not exist
and sort of other eligible resources
outside of just renewables.
In addition, States passed
a policy called Net Metering
sometimes called Net Energy Metering.
This is a policy that allows
you to put solar on your roof
and feed the extra kilowatt hours you make
from that resource onto
the grid and to be paid
for that supply.
And what rate do you get paid at?
Well, you get paid the same amount
that you'd be buying electricity.
So if you buy electricity
for, let's say 15 cents a kilowatt hour,
you would also be paid
15 cents a kilowatt hour.
And that's why it's net, right?
It's the difference between the amount
of kilowatt hours you bought in a month
versus the amount you put onto the grid.
And that would be your bill.
And as you can see here, again,
the vast majority of States
I believe the number is
42 passed these policies
throughout the 90s and early 2000s.
Now this effort has only
amplified in the last few years,
and we are now in a situation
where more than one in
three Americans live
in a place today
targeting 100% clean power
whether that's the States
that I'm showing here
or many cities across the country as well.
So you can see here that many
States have passed policies
targeting 100% clean power
with the exception of
Washington and Colorado.
None of them are really as
ambitious as the federal policy.
Colorado has a plan for
80% clean power by 2030
which is directly on the
pathway to 100% clean by 2035
and Washington state with it's
large hydro-power resources
is quite ahead of the curve here.
But the federal policy
that we're talking about
would really ramp up this ambition
and notably apply it to
the whole country rather
than having this sort
of piecemeal approach
that we've had today.
Now, what my book looks at is the backlash
that has come from interest groups
and even some members of the public
although largely interest groups
against the clean energy transition.
And what I show is that
fossil fuel companies
and electric utilities are resisting
the clean energy transition
in a wide variety of
ways then and the book
is meant to kind of
describe and categorize
and show the tactics that
these industries are using
to try to undermine what we
would call policy feedback.
So it's possible that many
in this group are familiar
with the term of policy
feedback, but just as a refresher
typically in political
science and public policy work
we think about how politics
as the independent variable
such as the election of president Biden
this fall reshapes the political landscape
and makes policies such
as this clean electricity
standard possible.
So we're thinking about politics
as the independent variable
and policy as the dependent variable.
Now, we don't have to think in that way.
We can think about how policy itself,
such as the passage of a
clean electricity standard
or renewable portfolio
standard in a given state
can reshape the political environment.
By for example, creating new advocates
like clean energy companies
or bolstering environmental groups,
and that they can come back
in later rounds and
further expand the policy.
So we're thinking about how
policy is reshaping politics
and then how politics can
then shift to expand policy.
And under that scenario,
we get a positive policy
feedback cycle, right?
An amplifying cycle where
a small policy at time one
grows over time to be a
bigger policy at time two.
And that was the theory behind
a lot of these policies.
That we would get a first
renewable portfolio standard
in a given state.
We would be able to increase that target,
bring forward that timeline,
and then maybe even pass one federally.
But that isn't exactly how
things have played out.
And that's because what I argue
is that the interest groups
opposed to your policy can actually learn
through that implementation of laws.
And they don't just kind of
go away that incumbents remain
in the political environment
and that they can try
to undermine policy feedback.
How do they do that?
Well, I'm gonna talk about that in detail,
but some of the ways that
I describe in the book
are things like lobbying
what I call implementation resistance
which is resisting policies
at implementation bodies.
In my case, public utility commissions,
primaries and elections,
particularly how the Republican party
has been pulled away from
climate and clean energy
through primary challenges astroturfing
and outside lobbying
as well as court cases.
And if you don't know
the terms astroturfing and
outside lobbying again,
these are policy and
political science terms.
Astroturfing is fake grassroots campaigns
where you pretend you're
a grassroots organization
when you're not.
And outside lobbying as a
concept from Ken Coleman,
which is about how interest
groups can organize the public
to amplify their own interests right?
So one maybe positive
example of that would be
if you're a solar company
that builds rooftop, solar
maybe you're gonna organize your customers
to lobby on behalf of
you in a policy fight.
Okay, so you probably know
that bills become laws, right?
But policy feedback studies
ask what happens next?
What happens after a bill becomes a law?
And we are interested in
looking at how policies
can reshape the political environment.
I want to argue is that
during implementation
that's when policy
feedback really takes hold
because that's when
resources are redistributed
between advocates and opponents.
And so the opponent interest
groups theoretically
lose some of their power and resources
and the supportive interest
groups, theoretically grow
over time right?
Now, what do these interest groups do?
Well, they don't just lay down
and die in the case of opponents.
And the advocates might
try to expand the policy
so that either go directly
to the legislators to try to shift policy.
And that would be a very
clear policy feedback cycle.
But as we know, from
the workup, for example,
Schattschneider, a really important figure
in policy work and political science.
They can also expand the scope of conflict
by bringing in for example, the
public as part of the fight.
And that is something
that electric utilities
and fossil fuel companies
have been doing in the case
of clean energy.
So we're going to give
you two examples of that.
In Kansas which is the
headquarters of Koch Industries
a major fossil fuel and
petrochemical company run
by the Koch brothers.
One of whom was now deceased.
You know, they had a
renewable portfolio standard
and it was doing quite
well as you can imagine,
Kansas is a very windy state.
But Koch Industries wanted
to roll back this policy.
And so all of a sudden
this group popped up
called the Kansas Seniors Alliance.
And these flyers started going around
saying that call your representative,
tell them to appeal this mandate.
So terrible, it's gonna
Jack up electricity bills
for all these Kansas
seniors who are struggling.
So a Lawyer was the person
who actually registered
this 501C3 organization.
And they wanted to know, you know
who was behind this organization.
And so what they did was they went
to that lawyer and they said,
hey, this was a journalist.
They said, "Hey, who are you working for?
Like, who's the Kansas Seniors Alliance?
There's no website, you know,
I'm just curious, who's involved here?"
And the lawyer said,
"Oh I don't work for the
Kansas Seniors Alliance.
I work for Americans for Prosperity."
which you may know is a kind
of public facing a front group
for Koch Industries, the corporation.
And it turns out that basically
they had formed this group
on behalf of Americans for Prosperity.
It wasn't just like a
spontaneous upwelling
of Kansas seniors.
Now here's an even more nefarious example
of astroturfing that
comes from New Orleans.
In New Orleans the utility Entergy
wanted to build a new gas plant.
And in order to do that,
they had to get a permit
in this case, from the city
council in New Orleans.
And you can see there was
a city council meeting
and a lot of people showed up.
A lot of people were
wearing the same shirt.
They had these signs.
Typically when you have
a grassroots movement
and organization, the
signs are sort of handmade,
they're colorful, et cetera.
But these ones were all
printed out in a mass way.
And these people got up to
the podium and they spoke
and they said, "We want
to build this gas plant.
That's what we think should happen."
So some journalists went up
to these people afterwards
and they said, you know,
"Hey why do you support the gas plant?"
And they said, "Oh, I don't
support the gas plant.
I'm an out of work actor.
And I was actually paid to come
to this meeting and to
speak up in this way.
And I was actually paid an extra money
if I was given a speaking role."
And it turns out that the
utility had spent $27,000
on a PR firm who had gone
and hired all these actors
to show up to this meeting
and pretend to be the public.
And of course this raises serious concerns
about sort of democratic representation
and participation when a meeting
which has only a certain amount
of time and a certain amount
of space for voices is being
taken over by front groups.
And I'll say, this is
actually happening right now
in my community of Santa
Barbara, where a front group
for a gas company has been going
to city council meetings to try
to block the electrification
of new buildings in the city.
And it's really been taking up time
from the public from participating.
And they've also been texting people
throughout the community
to spreading misinformation
about what this policy is about.
Now it's not just the public
that gets brought into these fights
over clean energy and climate action.
It's also the political parties.
And one of the key arguments
that I make in my book
is that one of the reason
why we've seen polarization
specifically asymmetric
polarization on renewables
is because the Republican
party has been pulled away
from renewable energy by utilities
and fossil fuel interest groups.
And the way that I see that
playing out in practice
is through primaries.
So I'm gonna tell you the
story of Russ Jennings
a representative in Kansas.
Russ Jennings was a Republican
from the Western part of the state
who was elected to the state house.
And his part of the state
actually benefit a lot
from the renewable portfolio standard.
He saw all these new wind
projects going into his community.
It was bringing in new tax
revenue, employing people.
It was a great thing.
And so when Koch Industries
started to put onto the agenda
the repeal of the renewable
portfolio standard,
he voted against it.
And the interesting thing is
it wasn't just Russ Jennings.
The first time a vote was
held to repeal the RPS in
in Kansas, as many Republicans
voted to keep the policy
in place supporting renewables as voted
to get rid of it, 44 to 44.
Of course the Democrats voted to keep it.
Now, the next time the vote happened,
which was just a few weeks later
suddenly a few less Republicans
voted to keep the policy.
And then a few weeks
later, the exact same vote
was held again and a few less voted.
So we have a nice longitudinal study here,
so to speak a panel of the same people
voting on the same bill over time.
And for some things, there
must be something intervening
in the time periods as like
a treatment that if somehow
shifting the votes of those Republicans
to be anti renewables.
Well, we happen to know
what that treatment was
because it was leaked to the press.
Another representative named Scott Schwab
said that Koch Industries
through their lobbies for
Americans for Prosperity
we're going to Republican
members and saying
"If you don't vote the
right way on this bill
we are going to primary challenge you.
You're going to lose your money
and you will find yourself
with a well-funded primary challenger."
Now you might say, well,
it's just one organization.
What does it matter
if you lose your money
from Koch Industries?
Well, let's think about how a Republican
in the state house gets funded.
Their number one source
of campaign financing is
the Kansas Republican party.
And what is one of the top donors
to the Kansas Republican
party Koch Industries?
The second biggest
source of donation funds
is the Kansas Chamber of Commerce.
And what's a top donor to the
Kansas chamber of commerce?
Koch Industries.
And the one of the third top donors
is Koch Industries themselves.
And so if a key actor like that
that has so much political
power in your state says
this is a litmus test item
and you refuse to change your vote.
You will find yourself losing your funding
and with a primary
challenger, and guess what
that's what happened to Russ Jennings.
He lost his funding and he
did have a primary challenger.
Now, in the case of Russ Jennings
Thankfully he won reelection in part
because the wind industry,
which through policy feedback
was growing, right?
They actually were able
to field their own
political action committee
and were able to support him.
So he squeaked through.
But even if these people win reelection,
think about what kind of chilling signal
that sends of the caucus overall, right?
If you've ever read Fenno, for example,
he writes about his experience
of spending a lot of time
with politicians and seeing
how paranoid they are about
how they could lose reelection
at any given moment, from an issue arising
in their district.
And this is the kind of thing
that really freaks out politicians
when they think I can be
primary challenged over this.
And so this is how, in my view, we've seen
the Republican party pull
away from the Democratic party
pull away from the
center on climate change
and really become an
anti renewables group.
And it's been very interesting
watching what's playing out
in Texas in the past week.
And I wrote a whole thread
about this based on my research
'cause Texas is a major case in my book.
Texas was a place where Republicans
were supporting renewables
in the late 90s and early 2000s.
In fact, the $7 billion spending
bill to build transmission
for wind energy was
sponsored by a Republican
quite a conservative
one from the panhandle
and the wind energy expansion
was also sponsored by him.
And yet today we see
people like Governor Abbott
blaming the boogie man, Green
New Deal and wind energy
and things like that
when it's not even true.
And what I argue is that's
because there's been a lot
of lobbying from fossil fuel
and utilities in that state
to really polarize the Republican
party away from action.
And this is unfortunately a
pattern that's been playing out
across the country over the last 15 years.
So you can see that in the early 90s
and early 2000s republican governors
were actually the ones who signed
these clean energy bills overwhelmingly
such as governor George W. Bush and Texas.
But then by 2005, we can't
find any bills that were passed
under Republican leadership.
And that asymmetric polarization,
which is taking place
at the elite level has
implications for the public.
Because we know based
on research from people
like Gabe Lenz, a political
scientists at UC Berkeley
that the public follows elites, right?
If the leads like Donald Trump
start to say climate change
I'm sorry, wind turbines cause cancer.
And they're terrible.
And et cetera, that's
going to trickle down
into what co-partisans
everyday Republicans
who are listening to him are
going to think about the issue.
And that's exactly what
we started to see around
2008 and 2009.
Now, thankfully, this
actually has recovered a lot
in the last few years, but
with the kinds of messaging
we saw last week out of
Texas, you could imagine
some kind of mass polarization
amongst Republicans happening again.
So my book looks at a lot of cases.
As I mentioned, Texas'
one of the main things
that I went and studied
as part of the work also
Kansas and Arizona and Ohio.
And if you're interested
in some of these stories
and you want them in
a more accessible way,
I actually turned to the
Arizona and Ohio chapters
of my book into a podcast
as part of this podcast
that I run called A Matter of Degrees
which is sort of a long form
documentary-style podcast.
And it brings to life
a lot of these stories.
So I'd recommend folks check that out.
And I've also written up
some of these things in places like Vox.
Now I'll just point out that although
many people are probably familiar
with climate denial
and how the fossil fuel
industry has spent decades
harassing scientists
spreading misinformation, et cetera
to the tunes of billions
and billions of dollars.
They, this has also been
perpetuated by electric utilities.
Electric utilities have made
a lot of problematic decisions
in terms of promoting a
wasteful energy system,
promoting climate denial
and working to roll
back clean energy laws.
And if you're just interested
in this part of my book
or you want to share it with a
class or something like that,
I published an excerpt on Drilled News.
If you'd like to get a copy of the book,
go to the Oxford University Press website,
which is just bit.ly/scp-book,
you can use this 30% off discount code,
if you would like, and
then it's like cheaper,
and you can share that
with whoever you want to.
And it also exists as an
ebook, which is cheaper.
If you like eBooks, I like
to read a lot of eBooks
and you can also get an audio book.
They turned it into an audio book.
If that's something you're interested in
I love audio books.
So that's how you can get a copy
of the book and yeah,
feel free to do that.
I now want to talk in
sort of the remainder
of my presentation about some
work that I'm currently doing.
And some recent policy
reports that I've released
I guess in the last month,
the first was with Sierra Club
and it looks at what utilities
are doing to decarbonize
their electricity supply.
And the second was with Evergreen
and with Data for Progress.
And it's really about
how can Congress pass
a clean electricity standard
as part of budget
reconciliation this year?
So the Sierra Club report
is called the Dirty Truth
About Utility Climate Pledges.
And what we did is we
looked at all the utilities
in the country and we gave them scores.
And what we found, and what we're supposed
to input for the scores.
The first was are you planning
to retire coal by 2030?
A lot of utilities are not
planning on doing that.
What are your plans to build new gas?
Many utilities have a lot
of plans to build gas.
Remember gas, fossil gas is a fossil fuel.
And what are your plans
to build renewables?
So very few utilities have plans on that.
And without a requirement
at the federal level,
the reality is that most utilities
will not move fast enough.
So this is a snapshot of a
bunch of utilities in Indiana.
And you can see here that
NIPSCO, great utility,
actually has plans to retire all its coal
by 2030 has plans to build no new gas
and actually has plans to replace 4/5
of its current electricity
with renewables.
So that's a very winning score there.
And you can see that the scores get worse
as we get further down.
And Duke in particular has not
enough plans to retire coal
is planning to build a
lot of new gas et cetera.
So although a lot of
utilities have adopted
voluntary clean energy pledges.
The point is that they are not the same
as a clean electricity standard.
They're not the same as a law
because there's no real
way to enforce them.
And indeed many of these utilities
that at the parent company level,
meaning a lot of utilities
have complex holding company
structures where there's a parent company
and then they own a bunch of utilities.
And those utilities are actually the ones
that make planning decisions.
So Southern company at
the parent company level
has made plans to you
know, decarbonize by 2050.
But then when they're
subsidiaries like Georgia Power
and Alabama Power are planning to do,
what are we going to build next?
They are not taking into consideration
that parent companies pledge.
And they're literally
saying in proceedings,
no we don't have to do that.
That's Southern that's not us.
So when you have a corporate
pledge that doesn't even apply
to the planning entities
within the organization
what is the point of the pledge?
And we can see that very clearly here
because as you can see right now,
utilities are not planning
to build enough renewables.
If we look at the 2019
coal and gas generation,
that's up to 1300 million megawatt hours.
And yet we're only seeing about
250 million megawatt hours
of plan to clean energy additions by 2030.
So there's no plan to decarbonize
the electricity system
without government policy.
Particularly when it comes
to coal plant retirement.
You can see that the
utilities in our report
that we gave F's too, which by the way,
we graded on a curve.
So you only had to get 18 or more
to be out of the F range because
that was the median score.
You can see that the
utility is getting F's
in our report have basically
no plan to retire their coal.
They are only planning
to retire 7% by 2030
and the utilities that
are doing much better
in the A and B category
have a lot of plans
to retire their coal.
So we know what's possible
to be making progress
just too few utilities
are actually doing it.
If you're interested in
looking up utilities,
we only look at the
largest oil and gas holders
and not oil and gas, sorry,
coal and gas holders in the country.
So it's not every utility.
It's 50 parent companies
in 79 subsidiaries,
but your utility might be listed here.
And otherwise you can just
look at other utilities
and you can get a sense of
what exactly are they planning
because although this information exists
it has never been compiled in this way.
And so you have to be, you
know, in a specific state
in a specific rate case
to know what, for example
Florida power and light is doing right.
But now you can actually
just go to this dashboard
and look it all up in one place.
And I think that's really
a very powerful thing.
So I'd encourage folks to
check that out as a resource.
Now, the other thing that
I'm working very actively
on is the federal policy opportunity
we have before us right now.
So we have an unprecedented chance
to scale up the leadership
at the state and local level
in 2021 with comprehensive
climate legislation.
And the way this is going to happen
is through budget reconciliation.
So for those of you who
have been falling this
the current COVID package
is going to be passed
through the fiscal year 20
budget reconciliation process.
And then after that's
completed, maybe in March
there's going to be another package
that will be the bike
build back better agenda.
And that will include a lot of climate
and clean energy investments.
And we're working very hard
to figure out how to do
a clean electricity standard
as part of that package.
These are just the pledges
that by made key pledges on standards,
key pledges on investments
and key pledges on justice,
specifically ensuring that 40%
of these investments are going
into disadvantage communities.
So is this doable?
Can we actually clean up
our electricity system fast?
The answer is yes.
If you go to the 2035report.com,
it's just 2035report.com.
There's an amazing study
which shows what's possible.
And they showed that we can
actually get to 90% clean
by 2035 and save customers money.
And that's because the coal
plants that are operating
in this country are
actually operating at a loss
but because many utilities are monopolies
there's no market-based
signal to put pressure
on those coal plants to retire.
And so utilities are
just charging customers
excess money to keep
those coal plants open.
Many coal plants could
be replaced tomorrow
with a wind energy plant
and save customers money.
And of course their health
and our air and our climate
and everything else.
And you don't have to
just take that from me.
The CEO of NextEra, a major
electric power builder
in this country has said,
"There is not a single economic
coal plant in this country,
full stop period."
So this is a fact.
So we released this report.
It's called A Roadmap to 100%
Clean Electricity by 2035.
And it talks through a
lot of the considerations
in this approach.
And what we really argue is
that the next two years are critical.
Anybody who follows federal policy knows
that we have as Kingdon would have told us
and policy windows.
We get these moments of opportunity
and they don't come by very often.
We haven't had one for a
decade on climate and energy
and this really creates a big opportunity
to increase the pace and scale
of clean energy deployment.
And the fact is, as I
mentioned, this is really
going to build on the
leadership of States.
It's also very popular and
it's very practical approach.
So this isn't something
we've never done before
already more than one in three Americans
live in a place targeting
100% clean power.
In the report we go
through a lot of details
about how this can be done
through budget reconciliation.
The basic rules of budget reconciliation
are that the policy has
to be primarily budgetary.
It either needs to be about expenditures
revenues and or debt.
And so the way we think about passing
a policy like this is basically saying
if you're doing the right thing, utility
if you're building four
to five percentage points
a year of clean power, you get money.
We will give you financial resources
from the federal government.
If you're not doing the right thing
you don't get that money
or you get less of it.
Like you're missing your target
and you have to pay an
alternative compliance penalty
a payment for every unit of
power that you were short.
So that's basically expenditures
and revenues into the federal government.
And it's actually quite different
from state policies that
involve a lot of credits
and trading and all this kind of stuff.
It's very simple.
So you get paid for doing the right thing
and building new clean
and you get punished if you
don't do the right thing.
And the important thing about standard
over and above just an investment strategy
which by the way, the investments
which would be the production
tax credit extended
for 10 years and turned
into a direct pay mechanism.
That's really the foundation
of all this work that's necessary.
But if you just give money
and you put no standards
or requirements on it, we
will not move fast enough.
We have to say that you have
to not just take that money
but you have to build enough clean power
at the pace and scale that's necessary.
There are a lot of other things
we have to do in this package.
I won't get into them here,
but the report does, if you're interested.
And I'll just say that we partnered
with data for progress on this.
And they did a lot of polling
on clean electricity standards.
They're very popular,
particularly amongst Democrats
and independence, but even
if you add up the sort
of don't knows for Republicans,
you're getting to about 50%.
So, you know, it's not
a very unpopular policy
when it comes to Republicans either.
I'll also say that we have some examples
of corporate leadership like Google
which is aiming for 100%
clean electricity by 2030
in real time at all facilities.
You know, a lot of corporations today
say they're a hundred percent clean
but what they're doing
is they're buying credits
renewable electricity certificates, RECs.
And they're saying that, you know
my facility is powered by clean power
but that's not real, right?
That's not really those electrons coming
to that facility are coming
from zero carbon resources.
And so what Google is trying to do
is actually deliver that stuff
to all its facilities real by 2030.
And that would be huge
because as far as I understand
Google is the largest energy
consumer in the country.
We also have some nascent
utility leadership emerging on this.
And I think we're at this inflection point
where utilities will hopefully
stop becoming opponents
to the clean energy transition.
And we'll see the massive
opportunity for them
not just in cleaning
up the existing supply
but in building out huge amounts
of new power to power
transportation buildings
parts of heavy industry, right?
The scale of the electricity system
is going to grow enormously
and utilities should see
an opportunity there.
In Colorado, essentially all
the utilities are committed
in law to 80% clean power by 2030.
And as I've mentioned, that is directly
on the path to 100% clean by 2035.
And Jared Polis, the governor of Colorado
was one of the people
to endorse our reports
based on his own leadership.
I do a lot of climate advocacy.
If that was not obvious
I run a podcast called
A Matter of Degrees.
It has lots of interesting episodes
about utilities and other things.
And I also contributed to this
book called "All We Can Save"
which is a really nice collection
from women across the
movement about climate action.
And thanks so much and I'll
stop sharing my slides now.
And I'm happy to take questions.
- Thank you so much for
a great presentation.
So to get started everybody, as I said,
I think using the raise hands function
would be the most straightforward
way to take questions.
I know that we had at least one
that came in the chat that
I think was from Daniel.
I don't know whether Daniel you'd like
to actually ask your question
or I could ask it for you?
I will go ahead.
So this question had to do,
and this is probably helpful
conceptually for everybody.
This question has to do
with sort of the difference
maybe between potential capacity
of renewable energy
sources versus the actual
sort of effective capacity
on a day-to-day basis.
So his question
specifically had to do with
whether sources like
solar or wind always have
sort of the maximum capacity possible,
or whether in a place like Connecticut,
maybe where it's not as sunny
does that potentially reduce
the overall contribution
to the energy grid that
some sources could give?
So I imagine that this
is sort of a common thing
that any discussion of renewable energy
is about sort of how much has to be built
to meet system capacity.
So if you could talk maybe
a little bit about that.
- Yeah, sure so when we
talk about any energy source
we can talk about capacity
meaning the size of the
projects that that is built.
So we would talk about like
a two megawatt wind turbine
or like a 500 megawatt coal
plant, or like a one gigawatt
which is a thousand
megawatts nuclear plant
something like that right?
Now each of those sources
has a capacity factor
which is how many hours of the year
is this plant actually delivering power.
And that's how we get
from megawatts in capacity
to megawatt hours in generation.
And so the renewable portfolio standard
or clean energy standard is on generation.
It's not on capacity, right?
And the reality is we have
to build a lot more capacity
for wind and solar
because they have a lower capacity factor.
So typically a wind might
have a capacity factor
depending on the wind
resource aka how windy it is
of like 30% or 40% or 50%.
Typically a nuclear plant
which is usually running all
the time, does not shut down
has a capacity factor of like
98% or something like that.
And often a gas plant maybe
has one of like 80% or 90%.
So that's what we mean by
sort of capacity factors.
And so we'll have to build a lot
of wind and solar and
depending on its location
it will have higher capacity factors.
So if you're in a more
Northern latitude, you know
you put a given size
like a 10 kilowatt array
of solar on your roof, the
amount of kilowatt hours
or megawatt hours it will
produce will be lower
'cause it's not, it's sunny there.
And so the bigger issue is not
so much the capacity factor
of a given resource.
It's what we would call
intermittency and integration.
So how do we make sure
that we have enough supply
at every given second everywhere as demand
because that's how the
electricity system works.
What was happening in Texas last week
is that there was too much demand
in part because when it got cold
and nobody has insulated houses in Texas,
Texas actually is like
bottom of the nation
in energy efficiency
people were using a lot more power
and then all these plants
were tripping offline, right?
And so what happens is when supply
and demand get out of whack,
that's very problematic.
You either have to shed
load, meaning, reduce demand
or you have to increase supply.
And in Texas, they
couldn't increase supply.
There was nothing else to bring online.
All these plants were
offline, they were frozen.
They didn't have all these gas plants.
They didn't have gas on site.
They didn't, they didn't weatherize them.
They didn't have any kind
of alternative fuel onsite.
And notably El Paso Electric
which is another utility not operating
in the restructured market of ERCOT.
They had weatherized their
plants because of an event.
I think in 2011 they had stored other gas
other resource onsite.
I think it was like diesel or oil
so that they had another fuel
and they didn't go offline.
So, you know, that is really about
how is the grid maintain reliability?
How do we integrate all these resources?
And as we get higher and higher levels
of what we would call
intermittent resources
which is wind and solar that
are not around all the time
we need to have more
transmission to connect parts
of the country for where,
you know if the Midwest
has a bunch of windiness
but the coast don't, we
can connect those two
and we'll have extra supply over here
and less supply over there.
And then we can spread that out.
So that's why transmission is so important
because it allows for this
geographic sharing of resources.
And it's also why things
like offshore wind are so important
because offshore wind has
a higher capacity factor
because the wind is
blowing more consistently
in the offshore area than it is on land.
So, and of course,
this is why batteries are really important
so that we can store power.
So that in any given moment,
when the let's say a
sun goes behind a cloud
and the wind files down we
can still be drawing on power.
So all of our grid is going to
have to become more flexible
and more resilient, but
that's what we have to do
no matter what, I mean
fossil fuels themselves
are making our grid less resilient
because they're leading to climate change
which is leading to extreme
weather events, like heat waves
and wildfires that are
destabilizing our grid.
So we can't continue in the
system that we've been in.
Fundamentally, that's
creating an enormous amount
of instability in our electricity system
through the impacts of
climate change itself.
So hopefully that's a little bit helpful.
And if folks are interested
in sort of getting a 101
on energy, there's a book that's quite old
but I think it's still quite good,
and it's free on the internet,
it's called Sustainable
"Energy Without the Hot Air"
and it's by David MacKay.
And you can download that
and you can learn some basic facts about
some of these things
that I'm talking about
and kind of get the 101
of different energy sources.
- That sounds great thanks so much.
So another question that has been put
in our chat that I'll read,
and maybe if Sebastian who's asking,
it would like to follow up.
So he asks your analysis today seems
to focus a lot on
investor owned utilities.
And he's wondering whether your work looks
at public owned utilities as well
and or energy production
and their progress on renewable goals.
And maybe whether there's a distinction.
- Yeah, so the reality is that
there's a view amongst some
in the left that public
power will be better
than if we so we already
have in this country
about four different types of utilities.
One is the investor owned, well I think
I have to do more actually
than just four but,
there are private corporations,
sometimes they're vertically integrated,
in which case we call them
investor owned utilities.
Sometimes they're operating
in restructured markets
like an ERCOT, but their
companies making profits,
okay that's the first type.
Then we have a type called
public power municipal utilities.
These operate typically
in cities and they sort of predate
a lot of the larger utilities
that expanded to become private companies.
And they operate outside of
public utility commissions.
And they're often
overseen by city councils.
So in California, we
have Sacramento, SMUD,
Sacramento Municipal Utility District,
in Texas there's Austin Energy.
So there are different places that have
kind of city municipal utilities.
Now nobody's ever studied
the electricity mix
of these different utilities.
I have started that project.
It's very hard to do.
And overall I think municipal utilities
have slightly cleaner power
but I think it's partially
because of where they operate.
And the fact that they're kind of smaller
and city city-based.
We have a third type, which is
called rural electric co-ops.
These are utilities that
came out of the new deal.
And I write a little bit
about that in my book.
And there's a book that will come out
maybe in a year or two by
Abby Spinak who's a lecturer
at the Harvard University
Graduate School Of Design
which talks about the whole history
of the new deal and the
rural electric co-ops.
Anyway, these are co-ops that were put
in places where private companies were
not expanding the grid and
they still exist today.
Co-ops are some of the
dirtiest energy suppliers
in the country.
They have very dirty energy
mixes, a lot of coal.
And there are big challenges
right now for a lot of co-ops
in terms of how do we clean
up their electricity mix.
And you can see that playing
out in States like Colorado.
And then we have also
federal power authorities
like the Tennessee Valley Authority.
The TDA is a terrible
utility, it's extremely dirty.
The TDA is actually one
of them that we study
in our us Sierra Club report.
If you're interested in looking at it
they have enormous amounts of coal.
They are planning to
build an enormous amounts
of gas and they are
not building renewables
at a fast pace by any means.
So in the conclusion of my
book and the conclusion chapter
I get into this discussion
of sort of public power
and sort of changing who owns these things
and changing their governance structure.
And will that solve a problem?
And my general view is no, it will not.
There have been attempts
in Boulder, Colorado
to break off from Xcel for like a decade,
it hasn't even happened.
And Xcel, meanwhile has pulled ahead
and is one of the fastest
renewable energy utilities
in the country.
Now, maybe that's in part
because of the activism
of those groups, putting
pressure on that utility.
So even if campaigns lose
to create public power
there can still be utility
in these campaigns because
they can put pressure
on the utility system to shift.
But I think that the view you
that ownership is a panacea
for our problems is just
not born out empirically.
When we look at the
massive different types
of utilities that exist today.
And the interesting thing
about the utility sector
is we have so many types of utilities
so we can kind of see in practice does
is this associated with clean
power or things that we want?
And in general, it's not.
And it's been interesting to, you know
watching the criticism of ERCOT
a restructured electricity system
in the wake of the crisis.
There's obviously some downsides
to restructured electricity systems
and the Texas restructured system
is actually quite restructured.
There's also retail choice
and that's in part why people
are getting such insane bills and anyway
but there's also benefits
to restructured system.
Namely, remember how I told you
about those uneconomic coal plants
in vertically integrated monopoly areas
that have not been restructured.
These utilities maintain these coal plants
because there's no pressure on them
from market signals to shut down.
So some advocates for
clean energy actually
want more markets because
then we can get signals
into the system to shut down coal plants.
So it's just way more
complicated than you think.
What I'm trying to say
about the utility industry.
And there aren't really simple answers
and I'm very open to,
you know, public power.
I know advocates who were really into it
who have been disappointed
that I'm not more for their campaigns.
And I really like those people
and I understand what they're doing,
but I just don't think empirically
that this is the path forward.
And let's also keep in mind
that we have like a decade
to clean up the electricity system
or 15 years and changing the structure
of these utilities will take a long time.
And it's probably just not on the timeline
that's possible when it comes
to cleaning up the system.
So that is my view others
may have different views,
but yeah I also write about that
in the conclusion of my book.
- Great, so we have one
question, hand, excuse me
that's raised right now.
- A bold questioner,
yes from the audience.
- Several more in the
chat but I'm gonna go
to the raised hand first, if that-
- Raise your hands, people
you'll get to go faster.
(laughing)
- [Vijjasena] Right, thank you
very much for the wonderful
like information that you've provided.
I just have a quick question
about what kind of
strategy, like, just to help
I guess me understand,
what are the strategies that these
I guess like these companies have in mind
when they like misinformed the public
they like publicly pressure,
well, at least the, right now in the age
of like technology, it's
very easy to publicly
expose their like acts to
pressure like politicians.
So they're taking like risky moves
which like come with expenses
of their own and also hurt
their reputation politically
and with the consumers.
So what's like their long-term
like strategy or like
do they plan on like sustaining
something like this indefinitely
and just keep burning money
to like lobby and push for false
I guess like misinformation campaigns
or what exactly do they
have in their minds
when they come up with a
strategy of like adopting change
or just continuing and
putting back change?
Like, can you try and
help me better understand?
Like, what's there?
- Yeah.
Yeah, thank you.
- That's a great
question yeah.
Well, the thing is that these companies
that I'm talking about
apart from the utilities
if it's oil and gas or gas utilities,
I mean apart from the electric utilities,
they're really in death,
they're in a life or death situation.
It's an existential
fight that they're having
over this policy.
And so you're right.
There are costs to doing these things.
The reputation will be tarnished.
So the thing I talked about in California
with SoCalGas, my gas utility
they created a front group
called Californians for
Balanced Energy Solutions.
They texted maybe 20% of
the people in Santa Barbara.
We don't know that's just an estimate
from one environmental group
they spread misinformation
and they got like hundreds
of letters written to the city council,
completely uninformed
about this ban on gas,
in new buildings.
And now why did they do that?
That got them a lot of bad press.
I wrote about it.
Others have written about it.
Well, they did it because if they lose gas
hookups and new buildings,
they lose their growth.
They're a private corporation, right?
They have to, well, they're not private,
they're shareholder owned, right?
They have to make growth,
they have to show a profits.
They have to show some
kind of future trajectory.
And so they they're fighting to the death.
They're kind of like a wounded animals
is what I'm trying to say.
And so they are willing to
tarnish their reputation
and engage in all kinds of dirty tactics
because they they'd otherwise
think that they're gonna die.
And they're trying to
forestall that timeline.
So, and it's quite bad
in California right now
but California public utility commission,
public advocate's office is like,
has fines out to them for this.
They have, I think, subpoenas
trying to get more information
from what they're up to.
It's quite a bad public thing.
There was a recent report about it in NPR.
And there's been reporting in the LA Times
and Mother Jones and other
places, but it's worth it
for these gas companies
because we are trying
to put them out of business fundamentally.
And so they are willing to
tarnish their reputation
and to engage in these
sort of dark campaigns
to try to stay alive
and I will say it does
work to some extent.
I went to the city council meeting
for the Santa Barbara city council
after this misinformation campaign.
And one of the city councilors
was even though he knew
based on the reporting
I had done the staff at the
city council, talked about it.
Other city counselors talked about it.
And the people who
showed up for the meeting
the front group came as did SoCalGas
but then a lot of advocates came
and talked about how
this was misinformation.
And it was, they texted all these people
but even still it's like,
he fell for it, you know
because he got letters from people
in his constituency and
that freaked him out right?
So what they're trying to
do is mobilize the public
use this astroturfing campaign
because that is something
that scares politicians
the same kind of thing we saw
in New Orleans with Entergy,
that example I gave.
So you're right it does
tarnish their reputation.
It's not a really great
long-term sustainable strategy
for their company, but fundamentally
these companies are not
sustainable companies.
They don't have a
long-term strategy period.
So this is just more
of the unfortunate same
when it comes to these companies.
- I think there's a follow-up
question actually on that.
So go ahead.
- [Vijjasena] Right,
sorry I meant to ask you
this like a two-part question.
Right, and so the second part is like
what's like preventing them from just,
you know painting their strategy
and figuring out maybe a way
for them to exit the like gas industry
and move towards renewables.
I mean, they're already
spending money, right?
So it's like sunk costs for them.
Why not rebrand, right?
Yeah I guess-
- So that's the kind of thing
that everybody's been saying forever.
A lot of these companies have a sort
of asset specificity and
human capital specificity
that's pretty difficult
to just pivot into doing something else.
One of the things they
did in San Francisco
over these gas fights is
that they gave a contract
to the gas company which includes
a lot of pipe fitters, right,
'cause you're laying down pipe for gas,
to build water infrastructure
and upgrade water infrastructure
because that's the same
kind of thing, right?
You're building pipes for gas
you're building pipes for water.
So there is some ability
potentially to retrain people
or to have the industry pivot.
But some industries
are not very pivotable.
If all you've been doing
is selling a fossil fuel
in the case of fossil gas,
well what else are you supposed to do?
Some utilities have a
utility side and a gas side.
And those ones can see a route out
because they can ramp down their gas side
while ramping up their
electric utility side right?
But a lot of them just
don't see an exit plan.
And this is also why we
need transition funds
to help workers out, to help
transition these industries
because they're not going to
be around in the longterm.
And we know one of the
things they do is they lie.
They say, we're gonna
have renewable natural gas
or they don't, you know, this is not true.
I think the estimate, I always forget it
but it's like 6% of the
current gas supply can be done
with renewable natural gas.
Let me fact check myself while I talk.
And, you know, if we only
have a very limited amount
of renewable natural gas, 13%, sorry,
13% of the existing demand
can be done by renewable natural gas
but we only have a certain
amount that we can produce.
This is by the way, from like landfills,
CAFOs Concentrated
Animal Feeding Operations
you know, factory farms, meat basically.
We only have a certain
amount of that kind of gas,
we should probably use it
for the sectors that
are hard to decarbonize
and where we're still gonna
need gas, like industry
not in our homes where by the way
using gas for cooking and heating
is literally poisoning us.
Even though we don't
recognize that there's more
and more research coming out, showing
that the air quality impacts
of gas stoves are terrible.
They increase the risk
of childhood asthma, 42%.
I mean, it's really quite bad.
The air pollution impacts
of gas in our homes.
So we probably shouldn't be
using gas in our homes anyway.
And if we have some renewable gas
that's going to need to be used in sectors
where we really can't
decarbonize other ways.
So anyway, yeah, it's not a happy story.
This is why we need transition funding.
One of the things that the
Biden administration did
in their executive orders on climate
was that they set up a committee
or a dialogue on transition funding to try
to think about some of these
sectors in our economy,
that aren't going away
and try to do a kind of planned transition
for those communities
and for those workers.
- Thanks so much I'm I have some questions
in the chat that I definitely will get to
but I'm going to go next to Sam.
- Hello, hey Leah, thanks
for your talk and discussion.
I'm curious to ask a question.
That's a little bit outside
the scope of the book
but extending a little more to
contemporary climate politics
about basically politics
around a Green New Deal
as opposed to policies
about, you know like rules
and caps and standards.
I guess the Green New Deal
could mean different things
but a policy that is about investment
in things, energy, jobs,
transit, et cetera.
And I'm curious from the state level
particularly if you think
all climate advocates
and all States decided to
pursue state renewed deals
instead of standards, if you think
like similar opposition would be met
but different active supporting organized
or unorganized constituencies
yeah that's about it.
- Well, the first thing
I'll say is that another way
of thinking about the Green
New Deal framework is standards
investment justice.
And so standards are not outside
of the purview of a
Green New Deal framework.
And a lot of the ways that people tend
to think about what's outside
are more like cap and trade
carbon pricing sort of
market-based mechanisms
to environmental policy.
The reason why we can't just
do an investment only approach
is because we will not get where we need
to go at the pace and
scale that's necessary.
What all the modeling shows
is that you give money
but it doesn't get you to
the deployment that you need.
And so we have to have some kind
of requirement to mop
up at the end of the day
and say it's great that
you're building stuff
but you actually need
to build enough stuff.
And then with climate change,
there's a huge difference.
And I think this is one of
the fundamental contributions
of the Green New Deal
thinking about the scale
and the scope of the problem
the pace that's necessary,
not just sort of saying,
oh we'll do a little climate policy.
We'll, put a price on carbon,
hope that it reduces some emissions.
We actually say here's how much
emissions we have to reduce.
Here's how much clean power we need.
Here's when we need it by.
That was one of the key things
in terms of reframing it
around 2030 in particular.
And I will say too
that the Green New Deal
framework resolution
included clean power as a
really key part of the approach.
So I think that the
approach with standards
investment injustice is
really the way forward
and that builds on the
Green New Deal framework.
And, you know, States can't really do that
because they don't have the power
of the purse, like the
federal government does.
And of course in this exact moment
that we find ourselves in right now
they're in terrible shape,
a lot of States and cities.
And so this piecemeal
approach that we've had
which is not getting
us where we need to go
is not going to be able to
leverage that investment.
So as much as I think a lot of groups
can get around investments
and be like, yeah, it's all carrots.
But at the end of the day,
there has to be a stick.
There has to be something to say
and if you move too
slowly, you're in trouble.
A carrots only approach will not move us
at the pace as necessary.
And we can design some of those sticks
to make sure that they're
not imposing costs
on consumers or, you know,
creating more inequality, right?
Like we don't have to have sticks
be like a carbon price that
is very consumer-facing costs.
We can have them be designed
in other ways where we're
not pushing the costs
of the transition onto everyday people.
So that really is the
way that a bunch of us
have been thinking and writing
and working on the
standards approach is really
in line with sort of the
Green New Deal standards,
investment justice framework.
- Another question that
we have in our chat
is about sort of the different types
of renewable energy that we might need.
And so this question basically
is talking about how maybe solar
and wind especially need obviously a lot
of land mass or water mass
for offshore wind areas.
And so what would the role
potentially be for nuclear power?
I mean, any large renewable
energy revolution.
- Yeah, nuclear thing I
spend so much of my time
either people loving it or hating it.
And that's my time, a lot of the time,
you know the reality is that
within clean nuclear counts
it's not a carbon emitting resource,
but the reality too is that
we're not building new nuclear really
apart from like Vogtle, one plant.
We are likely to be
losing some of the share
losing the share would, could be very bad
in terms of if it's replaced by gas,
which is what often happens.
So we need to be ramping
up renewables so much more
and we probably need
to keep nuclear online
to the extent that we can in
order to extend the timeline
to figure out how we're gonna
get to 80, 90, 100% renewables
without nuclear potentially.
So the hardest part of
nuclear is actually its cost.
It really struggles to compete on cost.
And so I don't necessarily see
a kind of nuclear revolution
coming down the pipe
nor do I see a clean electricity standard,
you know propping up nuclear
or anything like that.
what a clean electricity standard will do
is not allow retiring nuclear
to be replaced by gas.
It will require that if you
fall behind on your target
you have to make that up with clean stuff
and continue to make on
the pace that's necessary
because not only do we not want nuclear
to be replaced with gas,
we want it to be replaced with renewables.
We also don't want retiring
nuclear to put us farther behind
the timeline that's necessary.
So the standard can do all of those things
by basically saying, here's
the trajectory you're on.
You have to stay on that trajectory.
If you shut down nuclear plants
you've got to make up for that.
And you got to keep
staying on the trajectory.
So that's really the approach
that we have been developing.
And, you know, I understand
that some people are very pro-nuclear
and I am not anti nuclear
but I think there are
real barriers to nuclear
in terms of public
acceptance, costs, et cetera.
So I don't necessarily see
a lot of nuclear coming down the pipe.
I know others like Bill Gates, disagree,
and who knows maybe we'll we'll need it
because it is a higher energy density
meaning you don't need
as much land to do it.
And as we get to higher and
higher levels of renewables
we could end up seeing huge fights
over resources in terms of,
well why are you putting a
transmission line in my backyard?
Why are you putting a wind turbine?
And, you know, there are real trade offs,
real material trade-offs
in the energy transition.
And so if people don't want these wind
and solar projects everywhere,
you know then nuclear may have
to be something that's
considered as a society.
But so far people are pretty anti nuclear.
So I don't think that
that is the trade off
that will be made.
- So another question
that I have in our queue that I'll read
"It seems there is a potential conflict
between the 2035 target
of a zero carbon grid
and the 2050 target of a net zero economy.
If States start electrifying
transport and buildings now
perhaps meeting the 2035
target will be harder
if they do focus only
on grid de-carbonization the 2050 target.
Will get even more out of reach
with a late start on electrification.
How do you think this will play out
or maybe should play out?"
- I mean, we don't have
some insane electrification
pace that's going on right now.
We need to be real about where we're at.
I mean, I have an electric vehicle
and I am electrifying my home
but the vast majority of
people are not doing that.
So we can say that electrification
is coming any moment
and it will make it really
hard in the next 10 years.
And of course the package
will include incentives
to get that stuff going.
But we are not at a point
when it comes to EV adoption
or a building
electrification where we have
to stress about this at this moment.
I wish we were to be honest,
you know of course it would make it harder
from a grid electrification perspective
but we're not at that moment.
Keep in mind too, that even if let's say
we fall behind on
electricity, decarbonization
because demand is surging because of EVs
and a home electrification
building electrification.
That's not a bad thing
because we have to think
about the overall energy,
sorry carbon intensity of the
energy system of the economy
and what we already know
based on research from RMI
and lots of other academics
is that pretty much
everywhere in the country,
electrifying buildings,
electrifying cars is a win.
You win in terms of producing carbon.
So, you know, if we
somehow slow down the pace
of the electricity system decarbonization
but speed up the pace of
transportation and buildings
it's gonna be a net win right now,
the only sector that's been decarbonizing
is electricity right?
So, and the only viable pathway
to decarbonizing
transportation and buildings
and getting rid of the oil and
gas chunk is electrification.
So these things are not intention.
They're really in tandem.
As we move faster on electrification
we got to build more stuff
but it also is a way for
utilities to come on board
because they're gonna
see a massive opportunity
in building all this
stuff, serving more load.
I just briefed a utility
group this morning and said
"This is the biggest
opportunity if Samuel Insull
and Thomas Edison were alive today.
They'd be like, holy,
we could build all this
new stuff, it's amazing.
And so it's like a once
in a century opportunity.
So I do think that
utilities are about to flip
and become allies, which will be amazing.
And electrification is really the key
to that shift in their position.
- It's really interesting.
So I would encourage folks
to keep submitting questions
or even better raise your hands
but I'm going to take a prerogative
and ask one of my own here.
So I know we have some American
politics graduate students
in the audience in particular.
And I think certainly one of
the most intriguing things
about your book on a theoretical
to me is the move you make.
To sort of take on some
of the conventional wisdom
about policy, feedback, path dependence.
The idea that policy feedback
could be short-circuited as you say.
So I was wondering if you
could talk a little bit
about sort of where
your theoretical insight
into that came from, how
you noticed this in climate
and energy policy in particular
and sort of what it was like
to be working on this project
that maybe took a very different approach
to sort of I think one
of the classic themes
of political science and especially APD.
- Yeah, so I had two people on
my committee, Andrea Campbell
who's a very important scholar
in the policy feedback space
and Judy Layzer, who is now passed away
and who was a really important
environmental politics scholar.
And Judy in particular had
gone to a lot of workshops
in the late nineties at Harvard
when KKV was being written.
And she was really into
sort of that approach
where you're sort of
selecting with variation.
Like you would a
regression where you, like
here's a case where
policy feedback happened.
Here's a case where policy
feedback didn't happen
and you're trying to like
tease out the differences.
And so the early setup of
my project was in that way
because she really
believed in that framework.
The nice thing about that
is that it allowed me
to look at kind of the more unusual cases
the cases where things don't go to plan.
And in that way, kind of
look at the scope conditions
around policy feedback in
a more critical way, right?
Like under what conditions
do we get this lock-in
and is it deterministic?
Is it really path dependence
or are there forces
at work trying to undermine that lock-in.
And so it's not as if my book is saying
this is the most likely outcome
for clean energy standards.
I think a lot of people read it
and they somehow assume
that's what I'm saying.
No, carbon taxes and
other policy approaches
I've probably way more backlash
than clean energy standards do.
And I look at the cases
where the feedback doesn't take place.
So there's not representative,
there are cases
like California where
it's a positive cycle
or even Colorado, New Mexico, New York
all those places I looked
at that's the modal
or even the likeliest outcome.
By looking at the cases where
what we don't predict will
happen, you know, I think
that it gives us a lot
of insight in the forces
moving against policy
feedback and the forces
moving against lock-in
and help us understand
sort of organized combat,
condensation in politics,
interest group capture, all these things
that I think play out a lot,
even in the cases where
things are going to play
and we still have interest
group capture there
it's just normatively aligned
with what we'd like to
see in the world, right?
So yeah, the project definitely evolved.
And if you read my dissertation,
which is available online
and some people still cite
you'll see that there
are different cases in it
they are more set up in
terms of the KKV approach.
And I think I moved away a lot
of from that in the final book.
And, you know, Andrea
Campbell has written a lot
about how you know, the policy
feedback cases tend to be
I don't know if selecting
on the dependent variable is
the right way of putting it
but people look at successful
cases of lock-in, right?
They tell the happier stories
and so one of the things
I wanted to do here
was look at the more depressing stories
even though they're not the modal outcome.
I think it's really important that we look
at the cases that don't conform
to our theories as well.
- So if I can follow up on that
with another very political
science oriented question
which again, I think many in
this audience will appreciate.
Another of the concepts that
you introduced in your book
that I particularly find
intriguing is this idea
of the fog of enactment on a policy.
And I wondered if you could
elaborate a little bit
on what that is and why it matters so much
particularly that move again
from the actual legislation
maybe ambiguity's in it
to the contestation over implementation.
Yeah, so I think there's a
puzzle for policy feedback theory
which is that if we
have incumbent opponents
and they have perfect information
they know exactly what's going on,
why would they ever let a policy pass
that would undermine their power, right?
Why would they do that?
And yet policies pass
that undermined incumbents
power fairly regularly.
And so what I argue in the book is that
incumbents do not have perfect information
that in fact, no political actors,
whether it's policy makers their staff,
interest groups, the public
they don't know what legislation is going
to do during the negotiation process.
And I came to that based
on a lot of interviews
with people making laws
and various places,
interest groups trying to influence laws
and even looking at statements from people
like Nancy Pelosi and sort
of the congressional context.
And so I have quotes from
like fossil fuel lobbyists
who are extremely powerful.
And in the case of Texas,
literally like maintain a desk
in the relevant senator's office.
Okay three strong relationships.
And yet they said, "If we knew
that the policy would have done this
we would have blocked it, right."
Because when policies
are written on paper,
it's very ambiguous what
they're going to do in practice.
And one of the things, if you read my book
in the second chapter, I did a survey
of state legislators and
staffers, and I asked them like
how often did policies do what you think,
you thought they were going to do?
And especially in the
climate and energy space
I found that a lot of
staffers and legislators said
that they just didn't
do what they expected
a lot of the time.
And so implementation is where a lot
of the ambiguity in laws is ironed out.
Sometimes that ambiguity is
left in laws intentionally
in a way that Douglas Arnold writes about
sort of in traceability
where you say I don't want
to be held responsible
for whatever the outcome is.
So let's not put it in statute
and let's punt it to
the implementing agency
to make that decision.
Other times, you know
you're not really sure
what policy is gonna do.
You know people are writing
legislative texts on the fly,
you know especially these days
in both the state and the federal context
these bills stretched to the
hundreds, thousands of pages.
People don't even know what's in them
when they're voting on them.
You see this more and more and more.
And so that's where
this ambiguity comes in.
It's it's funny.
I tell the story of, I think
I told the story in the book
of the Trump tax cuts, they
initially passed the bill.
I don't remember through which chamber.
And it included something
that accidentally
would have actually reduced the corporate
You know, the amount of taxes
that corporations have to pay.
It would have made their
tax rate go up essentially.
And that wasn't what they wanted to happen
but they actually passed the bill
before folks read the bill and they said,
oh gosh we got to go
back and repass the bill.
And so they re pass the bill
to fix that problem right?
There's always so much pressure
in Congress about, you know, the timeline
of how we're going to
get this thing passed.
There's two chambers involved.
It's a very complex negotiating space.
And so in the book, I
describe all these factors
that make this ambiguity, uncertainty
and the fog of enactment, stronger
things like new policies
very complex bills,
technical policy domains, et cetera.
So, yeah, I think that
this really does reflect
how policy making happens.
And you know, now that
I'm somewhat engaged
in the policy process myself,
it certainly feels how it's happening.
Nobody really feels like
they know what's going on
including interest groups and
politicians and their staff.
So it's way more ambiguous as a space.
And you know if you've ever
read legislative texts,
it's legal it's very complicated
and hard to understand what it does.
Different parts of it can
interact with other parts of it.
And critically parts of federal law
can interact with parts of state law.
So when we have jurisdiction
across federal and state
areas that are shared
you do one thing at the federal level
and suddenly it causes these consequences
when a state policy passes
that interacts with it, right?
So this is why we are operating
in a very complex environment.
And I think that
oftentimes interest groups
don't know what's gonna happen
and they get caught off guard.
And that's how we can kind
of explain the beginning
of a policy feedback process
when incumbents exists
and should be opposed to that policy
ever passing in the first place.
- So speaking of your own advocacy
and public engagement in this area
I thought it would be good,
especially to conclude
and we have both graduate
and undergraduate students that
I know are deeply passionate
about these issues.
First, if maybe you could
tell us a little bit
about how you originally became
interested both as a scholar
and as an advocate in climate
change and energy policy?
- Yeah, sure, I write
about this in the book.
"All We Can Save", which is
a nice collection of essays.
When I was an undergrad, I got involved
in an energy conservation campaign trying
to get people to save energy,
like as a psychology major.
And I just, at the end of that felt
that it wasn't a big enough lever
that if we really wanted
to tackle climate change
and solve our problems
we had to work on the level of policy.
And so that's what I've been focusing more
and more on in of course,
I initially studied
people making these big changes
and it was fascinating
interviewing some of the advocates
who, you know, managed to get into law.
These sweeping changes
like a $7 billion transmission investment.
And so many times that
quote, like never doubt
that a small group of committed
people can make change
it's the only thing that ever has.
It's very true, like you might
feel like what can I ever do?
And, you know, you have
to build your career
and develop your networks
and everything else
but it is very true that dedicated people
who show up and who engage in the process
can really deeply shape policy.
And I learned that by
interviewing in my book
all these people who made that happen
or fail to make that
happen, but got close.
And that I think has
really inspired me to say,
well you know, we have
an opportunity right now.
I have skills and ability
to support that opportunity
and I'm going to do that.
And one of the skills that I have
is that I can communicate very well
to lots of different audiences.
I can make a technical area
understandable to people.
And so that's one of the things
that I lend to this effort
whether that's speaking
or doing podcasts, you
know, writing op-eds
making things understandable to people.
And the other thing that I do well
is connect people together.
And so I often think of myself
as like a yenta to the climate movement
where people reach out to me all the time.
And one thing we can
do is organize, right.
We can connect people with other people.
We can make connections.
We can, by working with
others, get new things done.
And because I've been very flexible
and not seeing my career
as I write academic papers,
and that's it,
I've been able to, for
example, write that report
with Sierra Club, which just
came out of some conversations
we were having about some
academic work I was doing.
And interestingly, I
abandoned the academic paper
because I felt it wasn't
really relevant enough
and moving fast enough.
And then I wrote this policy
report instead with the NGO.
So, you know, we have
choices that we can make
about how practical and
applied we want our work to be.
And at least as somebody
who works in climate change
and energy and the urgency of now
I feel that my work should
be as practical as possible.
And that's really how I orient myself.
- So I think I think your answer here
has given us some insight into this,
but I'm curious if you
have any specific advice
that you would give and maybe also
whether it might be different
to undergraduate students
or graduate students interested
in climate and energy politics
and policy specifically.
- Well, I would say
one thing that I did is
I took a lot of
interdisciplinary coursework
throughout my education
at the undergrad master's
and master's PhD level.
I took engineering, toxicology chemistry
you know, management, finance,
economics, policy politics
all kinds of stuff and
hydrology carbon capture
and sequestration, of course,
lots of classes on energy
and electricity and the, by taking such a,
and psychology by taking
such a broad swath
of training that really has set me up well
to understand the climate
and energy problem deeply,
because I understand, you know
biogeochemistry at a basic level,
I was in a chemistry lab in my PhD
for like five years atmospheric chemistry.
Obviously I don't run
atmospheric chemistry models
for my job, but I didn't think
that was like a waste of my time
or something I couldn't engage in.
And I did these interdisciplinary papers
with scientists who are working on models
and I helped explain, you know
what are the policy or
political implications of that?
And so having this knowledge
in a lot of different
areas is extremely powerful
for the climate and energy
space, because it is technical.
It is science-based,
there's so many disciplines
that weigh in on what we do.
And so that's been a really critical thing
in terms of my learning.
And I feel that it is
something that sets me apart
from many others and that I
can dialogue fairly fluently
with very technical people, even though
I am a political scientist
policy expert, whatever.
So I would really encourage
people to do that,
to stretch outside of their comfort zone,
take different classes learn
basic science and engineering.
Cause it really is a great
foundation for the work.
Work in interdisciplinary
spaces with folks
who are open to it.
And everybody I worked
with throughout the way
it was very applied and normative,
even if they were asking sort
of very positive questions
and doing very, you know, rigorous work.
And that always creates a community
of solidarity where all
of us are mission-focused
even if we come from
different communities.
So that's really what I would
say is probably my advice.
I would also encourage
people to join organizations
get involved in climate activism.
If that's something that
they feel strongly about,
you know it isn't
something that I do a lot
because in the early years, because I,
as you can probably tell
I'm a fairly nerdy person
I like studying and writing and learning,
and I didn't feel as
comfortable with protesting
or things like that
but other people might feel the opposite.
And I think we've seen just
how powerful protesting
is to the movement.
And this is something that
I of course do more now
and Ayana Johnson, who's one
of the editors of this book.
She always says that,
you know the climate
movement needs everything.
And so whatever your talents are
you should bring that to the movement.
You know, if you're write music,
some people write songs
about climate change,
or if you you know, like writing,
you can write about things.
If you like organizing, you know
you can lend those resources
to help organize groups
and get things done.
And so whatever you like,
whatever is your passion or skill
that is something that the
climate movement can use.
And so I would just encourage
people to bring their skills
to the movement.
Well, thanks so much for that
and that's really good
advice for everybody here.
I think to follow I'm, especially thinking
about all the
interdisciplinary opportunities
you have and if you're
an undergraduate Yale
and undergraduate student at
Yale, just the sheer amount
of different classes that you can take.
So one last question from me
which I'm sure is sort
of on everybody's minds
obviously you right now are deeply engaged
in your reports and your work
on the potential policies
that the Biden administration
can try to pursue through reconciliation.
I imagine also maybe some things
through unilateral action
at the EPA or otherwise.
So I'm curious, what
do you think the most,
what would make you optimistic
of something big happening
in the next two years?
Or what do you think the most
likely good thing to happen
in the next two years is
- Well, I'm already very optimistic.
I think the Biden and Harris
administration has staffed up
very aggressively on climate and energy.
I know many of the people
who are holding key positions
and they are dogged advocates
for the right side of history.
So I feel very, very strongly
that this is going to be
a landmark administration
on climate and clean energy.
And I think what I am looking
forward to is the next bill
the budget reconciliation bill that starts
at maybe a month or two on
on the build back better
climate and clean energy agenda.
I think it's going to be
absolutely transformative
to our society and I
think we're gonna pass it.
And that is not what I
would have said years ago.
You know, that's where the power
of the youth climate movement
of so many people from, you know,
governor Inslee running for president
also the impacts of
climate change in practice,
like heat waves and fires and hurricanes
like the IPCC 1.5 degree report.
There's all these factors,
Greta Thunberg, right?
Like all these factors have
just raised the salience
for politicians so much more of our issue.
And we're no longer a tier two issue.
We're really a top flight
issue, not just for the Biden
but for many senators and representatives.
So I am extremely hopeful that the package
will include a clean electricity standard
as well as other key investments
on buildings, transportation, electricity
making sure we deal with EJ issues.
We're investing in the transition
into disadvantaged communities
that are former fossil fuel communities
or former sites of
polluting infrastructure.
I just think that this is like
this is the Waxman-Markey 2.0
without cap and trade bill,
without the cap and trade part of it.
And yeah, it's like
the biggest opportunity
in more than a decade and it's coming,
it's coming very fast.
So I spend all day everyday
on that pretty much.
And I feel really, really hopeful
and excited that we have a chance.
And the general timeline
that people talk about
is like maybe March or April
until August or September
is when this bill would be negotiated.
So it's happening, I
would encourage people
to plug into organizations
as we get closer to bills
write to your Senator,
write to your representative
keep the pressure up because
we've just seen the power of
of people pressure to get climate change
at the top of the agenda.
- That's great to know and
that gives us all something
to look forward to hopefully,
and certainly to keep close tabs on
and perhaps advocate for.
Cause again, I know how many
of you care about this
that are in our audience.
So we're just about at time.
So I'd just like to say a couple
of things before we conclude.
One is I know that many folks in the chat
a few of you have asked whether the video
of this event will be available
because I think you want to go back
learn more because there's
just so much knowledge
and information packed
into Leah's presentation
for us all to take away.
So that video will be made available
and it will be directly emailed out
to those who have attended
today to go back and look at.
I would also encourage you all,
if you are users on Twitter
to follow professor Stokes
on Twitter, I think I am probably one
of many many political scientists
who follow you for many reasons
but as sort of the primary
source of our information
and news about climate
policy and politics.
So if you're looking for, you know
a great source of information
on all fronts on these issues
I highly encourage you to do that.
And more generally
I would encourage everybody
to go get this book,
it is fantastic.
Obviously, if you care about
climate and energy policy
you'll learn a lot from it.
If you're, you know an American
politics graduate student,
or frankly just anybody interested
in politics and a new take
on some class, a questions
and political science
you're also going to get
that out of this book.
So go do that and read it.
And finally, just thank you so much, Leah
for being with us today, I've
made your very busy schedule
of work towards a better
outcome in these areas.
We so appreciate it.
And I know that all our faculty,
students and staff have
learned a lot today.
So thank you very much.
- Thanks so much for
having me great to be here
with all of you
and hope everybody hangs
in there with the pandemic.